Section eight tape eight side two. So I was thinking this morning.
We've had periods in our history when really we had to bow our heads in shame. Just as it was in Minsk in.
Cutting off this country from the world except the queen. The queen's footstools that's what we were.
And it's happening again today. I think in the periods when I travelled extensively.
After Menzies and have proud of us for instance to be able as I go through customs to show my passport.
I'm an Australian. I'm ashamed of and. So those days of the Cold War. Do a favor to steering within me.
Now when I parted with before I went to him he was going to test me. To a job because he couldn't get a job here.
Professional people had to do that. And so.
I was going to the headquarters which was somewhere near the quay if I remember correctly.
To sort of get involved and do something for the festival. And who should I run into in the street.
And he'd lost his job in Tasmania because they said he was a security risk.
And he'd come back again he'd got a job in the meantime in a small engineering place at Crow's Nest.
But he still had his very lovely flat at North Sydney. And he said to me remember this.
And there was nothing between us before. It was just sort of made once or twice that was all.
They knew we made in Pitts trade. And he welcomed me with open arms and he said Oh he said.
I've taken back my subscription tickets to the concert.
Would you like to come such and such an act and his night was Saturday night and man by Saturday night
and I said to him.
Well I got tickets for Saturday night and he said oh OK but I won't take any one of Will make for supper.
Well I used to go alone. There is just something in me into a concert in. With a person who breathes. Music as it were.
So. And so we went to the concert and we went to the Monterey.
You know the Monterey was the place where you had a heart. With ice cream and maple syrup.
And the bass copy in town except for rep and. We had coffee and then he said to me I've bought some land.
And I'd like to take you and show you this. He said when the when the festival is.
And Helms was working very hard for the festival creating a magnificent design of Austria.
Where certain things are grown in geographically it for was beautiful and very informative.
And he together with a group of other professionals were working on it all for the festival.
He said When the festival is over we'll take you out and show you the land and our cigarette.
I think will entertain have coffee. So the first of all that.
One couldn't really call it a great occasion stuck out there in Fairfield of all places that. Anyhow. Well by there.
I was living.
In right at the bottom Street and the landlady and landlord lived in Hama Street just around the corner from me.
And they were both particularly the woman was very involved in the peace movement also which was very unusual.
But her husband was. A slum landlord and. Many houses in mine in Paddington which were considered slums at that time.
If you please. They were indeed not so much. But in mine. That's certainly one of my. Paddington.
She was a lovely woman who had a family of five children. I think. And he must have and twenty or thirty.
Round place all over the place. He came from Finland. And I lived down there in fourth Street.
So how many tickets in the place for a concert. Who to a concert.
And he said Well tomorrow I'm going out to the block that's what we always call it
when people began by land they were almost took up the block out of town he didn't have a car. And. I said I K.
So I packed lunch and picked him up from North Sydney and we got the train to Chatswood
and the bus from Chet's went up to. French's forest and then we had about a mile to walk to the block. And I was.
Taken with the beauty of the place.
It was the flowers were just absolutely magnificent and now here is where the House is going to be and you know what.
That day or couple a couple of weekends after that
when we were out the architect came out near the architect happen to be.
A person who was also involved in the festival. And he did it. Job for a parent or something. Drew up the plaque.
For the house and then I have to work at they now have to clean and prepare the ground for the foundations
and I just found myself working with him.
And I had a lot of very very happy for her digging for the foundations clearing and dignified and. And.
There was no water. Of course some interest in the heart of the bush. But at the very bottom of the hill.
There was there was a lovely stream that went down on the most formed beautiful pool of the part of the hill.
So once hundreds began to lay the bricks for the foundation. It was mine to up to carry the water for the cement.
And there was a lot of bartering here. That was going on in like it.
Most weekends we'd have extra people who were just friends who'd worked a day in the bush
and I'd give a hand with mixing the concrete. Laying the bricks and all that kind of thing.
And Marge of course to carry water and make sure they were fed well.
And there was a very good friend a neighbor in Sydney who would pick up the meat if we can get a half a lamb
or something like that that was divided up into three lot and I would take him says Lot up to the forest and.
Cook the chops for whoever was giving. But for the house.
And we had some marvelous there and then Hunt said Well what say we can help a little more often
and he had a three man table which is still left in the cupboard which I had to have. And so we began came up there.
Well behind this and in June seemed the month of June came and when we got married and Margaret Fulton was my.
Witness firsthand as witness and we went to the registrar made it all legal and. I had an unplanned waiting breakfast.
I was still hanging on to my house. Because I'd buy them in a few months after I'd moved in.
I actually got a house and back on my own around Tree Street I saw the house the other day.
It hasn't been enlarged in any way.
So I hang on to the house fearing Well if the marriage doesn't last at least I've got my house. That's what I thought.
And I'm not going to give it up so I put I sublet it to him. Just in case things didn't work.
When we got married we went back to have it all the previous night.
Margaret said to me a couple of not before but Margaret's into me.
What are you going to efface we're I said Margaret that maybe sort of mark.
Oh you can't wear that outfit to get married. Did it might be the only time in your life you get married.
You got to have a decent well have father was Italian and she could so's Well if you could cook.
And she said made up quickly to get some nice fabric.
And cut this out and ran out up that night and it had hand sewing with alarming and I did that part of it
and that was my wedding suit proposed. First and gray. So. And then she said well you will break the hilt.
I suddenly thought about a breakfast. You have to have just after breakfast.
Well that she had just started working in her kitchen for Women's Day.
Which was quite a magazine different to what the rubbish.
And she prepared the breakfast in her kitchen and handed over to her flat.
And there we had Lynne Fox MARGARET You couldn't who is my fairy godmother.
Who came down with a wedding present a present of a pressure cooker. Something that I have forgotten.
And I suppose you know all the boys have been say six of us. We had this pattern and these my.
Fresh cream cakes with Drury.
Was wonderful and I always recall hand saying oh my coffee and Margaret followed him into the kitchen.
You can't use that on this cafes and she brought good coffee Granny didn't use the well that was waiting
and I still hung on to the house and because I thought this MARTIN Don't be too sure.
And said the first year was very rocky thirty two for you and I and independent
and I never expected anything from like most brides would. And I got to that house. You never know. So.
Fifty two what men think if you. Yes that's right. So I wish and work to show. Factory to get a lot of money.
And I paid the rain while Hans put his salary into the material for the house at the printers forest
and it worked very well and for five years every year every week in we went out to.
And then the work the terrible fires in the house in the forest and since our house escaped.
We thought it was time to go and live in and quite finished by.
It was beautiful just lovely living in the heart of the forest and the closest neighbors in half a mile away.
What have you and people in fridges forest who were living there then
and there were very few thought that we were quite Applecross to build it in that house.
You know they had Fibro batter boxes.
They'd both the land because it was still oh yes we're not going to look at it one day when you've got.
And little goes out and drives past and has a look. So we lived in that house for thirteen here.
And really we wanted to get into the International School which was very close to Macquarie University
and so we thought to get her there.
We've got to move house and that was the only reason why we moved from fritters forest.
So we moved to Kerry OK we moved into this house. It wasn't like this when we came here.
There wasn't a tree in the front. We used to sit up the front on the wall and have afternoon tea.
And if a car went by You'd have a look to see. Goodness me there is a camera. Absolutely absolutely. But I want to.
Back to the house of trenches forest. It was a house that.
Had some magnificent of its New Year's Eve night we would have as many as fifty sixty people
and there were people from the new theater. And there were people from.
The Labor party the Communist Party from the Hubert society from from the back talk.
One night they we had four different families by the name of Moore.
And people were satisfied with such simple things like I would do the preparation.
Some people might come with a bottle and some may not but the emphasis was never on the ground
and the food the emphasis was on. Singing. And companionship.
And they were marvelous parties and that would not only be night we'd probably throw.
Here big party that the what many many people came to their house for dinner.
One of our favorite guests was Gordon Batten. Who created. I picked the big carrying business and at that time.
Gordon was a millionaire living in Castle. I was very friendly with his wife who had a brain.
And the Golden came off and for dinner.
And there's days like you'd have a bottle of wine for a dinner party of eight
and everyone would just have a small glass of wine and that was it and the conversation would flow.
It was just wonderful. And I want to cation your C.
Street was a bit turned off
when I told her we were going to live a different stars because Hooper so easy for her to hop.
You know Sydney and cook up some plants but friendships apart first was another kettle of fish.
So I thought I'd better invite her actually you know one said yes he can bring four of your favorite people.
And he was this famous I have with four main. And I continue so hard for that dinner party.
And I had a good butcher who sold me. Well I'm a new curtains for the dining room. All yellow.
And I had yellow Dafoe deal looked beautiful and the dining room you could look through the window
and see the lighthouse at Brooklyn really seduce Iraq. And a couple of other hangers on.
But this woman with a golden spoon. Walked into the dining room looked around and.
Goodness may now all of this does look beautiful and are said Oh why did she looked at me
but you're not supposed to be eating that. And we were living off from Constable.
We had to make things straight
and took it for granted there should be servants there doing that you should be out you know speaking public speaking.
Absolutely. You know that's what you should be doing at all.
Then she said a story about She'd put off until the beauty of. Stories of. Years growing up but. Upside of crafters.
Forgotten and that doesn't matter. And she said how well she got on with the head groom.
And he selected the best horse for her. And she said that's what it's about.
You've always got to make sure you have to best horse. If you want a good job and knew I was good.
Now I know that you shouldn't be in the kitchen. Preparing a dining room for us.
Well I'd cook to feel a huge dinner and so forth. Anyhow. So that house carried wonderful stories.
And people would never leave before midnight
and very often House would pick people up as far as Bond in a hard drive them in the early hours of the morning.
If they were interesting people. And I was just thinking the principle of. What is a school of.
Eversley at present is the wife of a man who. During the sixties and he often came to our place.
When we were organizing against the war in Viet Nam very often our place would be the meeting place
and then people would hop in a cast and go down to the beach fronts for meeting. What have you. But it was.
On one occasion. They came to our place. Three Japanese man one. I was in the parliament.
The Japanese parliament and they were out here on a mission for peace. And I've got some photographs of them.
And we weren't living for very long in the forest when they were brought out to our place
and I was considered one of the leading lights of the peace movement so they thought if they could bring the Japanese
out. Well these blokes came through them lovely people.
One was a journalist one a member of parliament and another I think just scored
and they were proved a state member of parliament. And. MARGARET The. Margaret by the way helped to build a house. And.
So by their first crop and I had my very. And those days I prayed. And I gave them a very homely lunch time for you.
It is really sorry. And I was very proud of my. And when the member of parliament said it was about a profession.
Well I just went to him and I thought well maybe I can make this partisan so I'm by the road.
But he looked and he asked Did you run a sheep almost vast area of land we.
It was a good thing because I had nothing but bitterness. I couldn't. I couldn't come to anything that was happening.
And in a way that was. I had come here to be ambassadors for peace. Absolutely. They were true Ambassadors for Peace.
So it was very.